so today I have a bit of a game for you
we're gonna play a round of would you
rather so just picking between the two
options and then briefly telling me why
you would choose one or the other
so first up would you rather screw up
every single take yourself or have
somebody else screw up your best take
some you scrub my best take who is the
most likely to screw up a take in this
cast David Oliver actually nobody was
really screwed anything I mean cuz David
and I had such a short hand together so
it was like it couldn't screw each other
up because you know we we met and we had
this chippy great relationship [ __ ]
people like a father and a son you've
been separated whatever so when it came
to him to put on all his couch events
you know the horns and the tail they
were just like whatever because he never
saw them as weird so there's never any
sense of seeing somebody on the set
who's six foot five in red and Goins
it's weird it's just that's you know
that's tell boy and we talk so it was
natural so he'd speak totally normally
most the time and you know well all the
time so you never knew so there was no
real screw-ups unless they were he's
always lighting the screws oh let's get
that favor I always like him it screws
up though is fiddling with some other
lamp nothing right
well nowaday know they have it did you
know on the spit no I mean you've no
idea on nowadays on movies what they've
got I mean you ask any any interesting
you ask any DP 15 years ago they go I
love the days of film I want to go back
to the days of film when I I could feel
it in my hands and cut it not one of
them would go back and do film anymore
cuz everything they can do anything yeah
fiddling there's gonna die on this
everything electric the dis sense you
know whatever oh yeah a little punchy
what you want to say excuse me doctor
now you know we you just go away and
fiddle somewhere else while we act the
scene which is Rick no just a second
changing the game big time it makes
their job hopefully a little easier and
it also gives them an idea yeah yeah
nice a little easier yeah
it gives people out there the luxury who
might not have had it before it to be
able to make oh no the thing is you can
do whatever you want no Amy not secret
and why then this is what this big
movies are about I mean it's like saying
how can you outdo and you'll continue to
think of what will happen when VR comes
in which everybody says you know it's
gonna happen and be people poopoo it
forever but technology always wins out
in the end you know you can't help it
it's like saying you change you say no
you will have to change before the
futures gonna change cuz it's gonna
happen anyway
yeah but VR will be extraordinary I did
a I did a thing as like a 10-minute
short which then it was a what do you
call it an animation film but they did
in VR it was incredible I've watched it
so god knows how they'll figure it out
but elbow in VR can you imagine amongst
those scenes is I would be in for that
yeah all right would you rather speaking
of this being a bit of a remake would
you rather see the Deadwood movie remade
in 10 years or John wick remade in 10
years oh gosh probably 10 years John
wick will still be going I would hope so
oh ma you know you never don't care they
might be running the hotel and
everything by that but you don't know I
mean it's like no Deadwood we just
finished our sword the other day so we
Tim and I few comments I think it's yeah
it's okay I like hearing that
yeah it's good again it's you know don't
expect an episodic piece it's too
difficult when you're gonna make a
two-hour movie of an episodic TV so
there's a lot of but I think they got
the setting right they got the links
right on they got everybody back which
is really great because they could have
made you know 7l ride the high country
together that wouldn't have been dead
word that would just be me and Tim sort
of catching enough this is Milch
Deadwood yeah
circa 10 years later statehood
difficulty characters have moved on
there little change which is great
should be John White's the world of John
wick is being is more than the next one
I mean yeah that'll be more about the
high table you find out a bit more about
you know him his background whatever
preparing for who knows what the hell
next time I can't wait gets bigger I
think you'll enjoy that yeah
you